you
[Music]
okay well let's go ahead and get started
I want to welcome everybody to our next
edition of data club this our first one
in the new year my name is Eric Olsen
I'm on the core OS are basically the DEP
a developer platform team within cosign
which is part of Azure and if you
haven't been data cut before just
reminder what we're here for
basically these are training and sharing
sessions for data I'll say data science
hub boot also includes data engineering
related work and there's a number of
different formats we use which you
probably seen before if you've been here
before but this is our place for
collaborative learning our chance to
share with each other and actually learn
from it what other people are doing and
the types of problems are working on
these are basically training sessions or
information sharing sessions to help
grow the capability the organization or
a lot of times just make people aware of
what's out there if you're if you're not
aware and it also builds you opportunity
to build connections with others in the
data community who might be working on
similar problems who find help
essentially so as a networking
opportunity and so our first real light
data Club is to talk about data club as
to participate and learn together that's
that's how we leverage our learning you
get better and then if you see something
you like here be sure to share it with
those that couldn't attend or reminded
there's a recording that can get it
afterwards and they can check it out
and then finally looking ahead we have
these these sessions about every two
weeks
so our next session is on February 7th
our tentatively right now we're going to
be talking about a jury ignite impact so
some of the data analysis around in
ignite and then on the 21st we'll be
revisiting the business intelligence
craft they're enormous big to get some
updates of what's going on there so
we're about commercial space if you want
to keep up with information about these
sessions you can join the data club
alias on i.t web you'll get all the
announcements and all the meeting
requests and then if you miss anything
here today what I'm talking about then
don't worry you can always go to
aka.ms/offweb
so you can give us feedback on what you
liked what you didn't like what you'd
like to see are things like that and
with that I will now turn it on to David
to talk about neo 14
hi everybody thanks for taking the time
today I love talking about graphs let's
do some of that today we're going to
talk about introduction to neo4j and
graph databases since this is a data
science group I do want to towards the
end get to talk about graph algorithms
and some of the data science
applications but because graphs
represent such a different way of
thinking about data we need to go
through some basics first
um this is who I am I'm a partner
solution architect at neo4j I have a
pretty fun job there because about 50%
of it is business and about 50% of is
technical I do a lot of integrations
between neo4j and some of our strategic
partners Microsoft and Azure being one
of those but I get to play a lot and I
get to play with a lot of new fun stuff
from all over the industry and that that
makes me happy you can get me on Twitter
send me an email if you have any
question and after this session a couple
things that I want to cover in this
session go over an introduction into
graphs and neo4j and what the
relationship between is talk a little
bit about why people are using graphs
and when you would use graphs versus
some of the alternatives that you have
we're going to talk about the underlying
property graph data model because you
can't really do rigorous analysis or
data science unless you understand
what's underneath we'll talk about this
cipher query language and about how we
query and manipulate graphs talk about
some data import and then how we develop
applications we're going to have some
demos in here too so as we go we will
have one demo from Ambrose that's about
Microsoft specific stuff and then I'll
show you some other demos to give you a
kind of a flavor of the toolset around
this will also talk about graph
algorithms and data science applications
so if you are one of those technologists
who doesn't want to just listen to
slides and high-level theoretical stuff
take note of this if you want to follow
along and actually use the software
while we're talking try out things that
I'm talking about on the slides this is
how you do it we are in the azure
marketplace so you can search for neo4j
Under
and launched a single instance universe
3.5 dot one is the latest that's on the
Azure catalog or if you know absolutely
nothing about neo4j and this is your
very first experience go to neo4j
sandbox comm it will allow you to launch
any of the sand boxes that you see on
the right hand side and get you to a GUI
really quickly so you don't have to
think about you know what port do I go
to any of that stuff sandbox is the
fastest way but there is the azure way
to on sandbox you're going to get a free
temporary instance that only lasts for
about two days I think
and it starts preloaded with data so you
don't need to know how to load or query
or do really anything with an empty
database so with that out of the way
let's start talking a little bit about
graphs and the basics so why graphs um
you know I'm kit was saying at the
beginning of this session he got this
sticker at our conference graph Connect
graphs are everywhere we truly do see
that basically the entire world is a
graph and everything is connected you
have people places and events that are
thoroughly connected with one another
companies and markets countries history
of politics there are so many endless
examples of these things it's it's very
natural and visual for human beings to
connect things in their mind as graphs
rather than to use some of the other
formalisms that we've become accustomed
to as computer scientists and as
technologists we learn how to think
about things in terms of relations and
sets and json documents and things like
that but that's an abstraction that
we've mapped a more reasonable
understanding on to not how our brains
work our brains tend to think of these
things as connected nodes and edges
whether it is flights going all over the
globe or any other use cases so before
we get into the the bits about neo4j us
talk a little bit up on the business
side of what people are using neo4j and
graphs for our business is primarily
focused on the global 1000 or we have a
heavy presence in retail finance and a
number of other sectors to give you
three concrete examples of
how we're transforming large enterprises
we do real-time promotion
recommendations for a lot of these big
retailers and so you know whenever you
see that somebody has had these records
cyber monday sales part of that is you
know consumers buying more online and
part of it is that the retailers are
consistently getting smarter about how
to do product recommendations a lot of
that product recommendation stuff is
driven by near forge a behind the scenes
in that we can model the products and
who is buying what as a graph and then
we can create social recommendations for
users you know you might like what your
friends have purchased and any number of
other recommendation approaches using
near forge a Marriott uses us for
real-time pricing with 300 million
pricing operations per day um one of the
other things that Marriott has found and
you know we can talk about this a little
bit more and in architecture parts but
we tend to require a whole lot less
hardware and we get to index free
adjacency and talk about how the
database works a little bit you'll
understand why that is
folks are frequently finding that they
can replace large fleets of relational
database clusters with fewer instances
of a neo4j graph database when they're
really focused on real time
relationships and we also work with
large postal services for handling
package routing in real time and so if
you think of the Traveling Salesman
problem or a network of roads as being a
graph of sorts package routing is full
of shortest path type queries I need to
get a package from point A to point B
going through the fewest number of
logistics hops in the middle so that's
you know what you would think of as a
fundamentally graphi problem just to
kind of go through a number of other use
cases we cover in two categories
internal applications we have a lot of
folks using us for master data
management and so they would take the
metadata from all of their systems and
then put it into neo4j and draw a lot of
correspondences back and forth to say
this field in this system is equal to
this field in this other system a
metadata catalog if you will we get used
for network and IT operations where you
have to understand the topology of a
network and how
of your infrastructure relates and this
is used for things like critical path
analysis so which router if I knocked it
down would take would knock the whole
data center offline that's an example of
another kind of a graph a use case and
fraud detection so a lot of our
financial clients will put transaction
data into the graph and then we'll ask
you know maybe I sent five thousand here
five thousand there five thousand to a
third location but if all three of those
recipients of the funds are controlled
by the same party in aggregate have
transferred fifteen thousand to somebody
and so it gets used to sniff out
financial fraud in customer-facing
applications real time recommendations
particularly products for retailers
graph based search and Identity and
Access Management so that's what graphs
get used for what are they in much the
same way as a relational database has a
set of tables rows columns and schema
let's talk a little bit about how graphs
are structured fundamentally it boils
down to nodes relationships properties
and labels which will go through a node
is simply an object in the graph and it
can be labeled a label is like a
semantic category much as you might have
a an entity in an entity relationship
diagram so in this particular graph
we've got persons and we've got a car
relationships relate nodes by type and
Direction relationships in the air for J
are always directed you may traverse
them undirected if you want but they
always fundamentally have a direction
relationship so a relationship always
has a type so if you are traversing a
relationship you can segment that out
and say that you only want to traverse
certain kinds of relationships not just
any way that these two nodes are
connected so in this particular case we
can tell from this really simple graph
that these two people love each other
they live with one another one owns the
car but the other drives it regularly so
properties are basically key value maps
that get associated with
nodes and relationships they can go on
either and so by adding properties on
top of these nodes we realize that it's
Dan and Ann who love each other and that
live with one another dan has a twitter
handle and when we look at this
relationship drives Dan drives the car
we can put metadata on the relationship
and assert that that's only been since
2011 so basically you can think of a
node and a relationship as a property
container where properties are simple
key value Maps yes sir
my relationship is the same as pages yes
so in the graph world sometimes people
refer to vertexes and edges we tend to
talk about nodes and relationships
because we find that language is more
accessible but in the math literature
you'll see vertexes and edges and it's
we're talking about the same thing yes
relationships so there are two person
right or you have some sort of like
ontology on top like between person s
entity and okay so there's a couple of
different ways of going with that
question there is not an on the the the
question for those who didn't hear it is
is there some sort of an ontology on the
top that specifies what kind of
relationships you can have we're going
to talk about constraints you can assert
constraints that certain kinds of nodes
must have certain kinds of relationships
however those constraints are optional
neo4j does not have an ontology layered
on top of it and those sorts of schema
constraints are optional right so and
furthermore the constraint may assert
that that you have to have a
relationship but you cannot for example
assert that there could never be a
drives relationship between two persons
okay that would be a different sort of
constraint does that answer your
question for now we're going to be
talking more about constraints any other
questions before we go on okay so just
quickly summary here nodes or entities
with complex Val
types relationships connect them and
structure the domain properties are
basically these key value pairs they
tend to Express metadata about your
nodes and your logical entities in your
domain and labels group nodes by role
and so usually you think of labels as
the the entities in an erd nodes you
would think of as the instances the rows
in a table and relationships can be
thought of as joins which will go into
much more depth on that yes that that is
true so the question for those who if
you can't hear it online is how do
labels differ from properties so labels
are an optimized indexed way of scanning
to a particular subset so you actually
could do it either way you could have
nodes with no label at all and then you
could have a property that says let's
call it type right and then say a node
with type equals person all right when
we get to how the cipher query language
works labels are a lot more intuitive to
use in terms of structuring your domain
and they're also more performant
underlying in terms of how the database
is implemented but you could do it
either way like if you came onto our
community forums and asked that question
we would probably say you can do it both
ways but please use labels for lots of
reasons okay one of the really cool
things about this graph model that we're
talking about is a property that we
would call whiteboard friendliness when
our field engineers go out and work with
customers frequently the customers have
not been exposed to graphs before and
they don't really know how to approach
working with graphs and modeling their
data so just in a very human open way we
get a whiteboard out we get some markers
and we say so tell me a little bit about
your domain so you've got customers and
so you draw a little something on the
board and you say off they buy products
so let's draw another little circle
called product and then create a link
between them and so you you have this
elicitation session if you will where
you're trying to get them to talk about
their domain what some
to them what the data means and you draw
that out and so to give you a simple
example if we were talking about movies
and actors you might end up with a
whiteboarding session like this so you
got Tom Hanks who acted in Cloud Atlas
Hugo Weaving was also in Cloud Atlas but
you know I don't know if you guys like
the matrix at neo4j we love the matrix
okay it's in the name people all right
we love the matrix anyways so Hugo
Weaving was Agent Smith he was in the
matrix and the lana wachowski happens to
direct both of those movies so you can
elicit this information from use or get
this really rough whiteboard sketch
going right I don't know like wow look
at that that's a graph we got a node
called Tom Hanks who acted in Cloud
Atlas and so on and so forth so that's
how simple the translation was we
literally just applied this on top of it
then we're gonna do is we're gonna slap
some labels and we're going to property
if I if you will what do we care about
people what do we care about these
movies right so a person who is an actor
has a name and maybe a birthdate when we
say that they acted in the movie it's
probably important to know what role
they played so we'll give that a role
property Cloud Atlas was definitely a
movie and we're gonna want to track what
year it was released in and so on and so
forth so when we say white board
friendliness this is what we're talking
about go from I understand my domain
inside of my own head elicitation
session to a rough model that we can
query really quickly all right now I
don't know about you I work with
relational databases for years and years
and years and it's very easy to get
bogged down in these conversations if
should we be third normal form or not
and and what the data is and how we
think of it often get very radically
separated from one another okay so this
is a this is a screenshot of what the
result of this is going to look like as
concrete data inside of neo4j when we
get to the demo you'll get to see these
springy cool graphs moving around so
we've talked a lot about graphs the
property graph data model so that brings
us to neo4j itself
hopefully at this point in the
presentation it's not gonna come as a
big shock or surprise but new 4j is a
graph database a couple of properties
about neo4j we support strong acid
transactions so we are not an eventually
consistent database you get strong acid
guarantees it's very very fast and I'm
not going to ask you to accept that as
like a marketing claim we're going to
talk about index free adjacency and I'll
be able to tell you in terms of data
structure why that is so we can get two
to four million operations per second
per core it comes with both binary and
HTTP protocols that are have a lot of
different language supported drivers
we'll cover that we have a clustering
approach that provides for high
availability so you can have multi node
clusters and you can survive the failure
of multiple nodes in your cluster and
still retain those strong acid
guarantees and stay in operation and no
size limit yes
so it's VM that you can or you take this
and put it into your how do you actually
is it like service being able friend is
it a service we will form it like Siri
set yeah essentially you need to install
to me take care of it yourself it is not
available as a managed service at this
time
that's something that we're actively
working on so it's provided as a VM
based deploy so yes you you take care of
the VMs once it is launched okay but you
can of course create your own VM and
then install it much as you would any
other software package but I wouldn't
recommend doing that we provide all in
the azure marketplace it's way faster to
just launch the version that we offer
that's already configured nicely and so
on and so forth ok so it's a native
graph database its schema free schema
free is a little bit misleading it's
kind of schema optional we have many
schema constructs but they're not
required that you use them let's see it
gives you a really nice developer
workbench that you'll see
and one of our superpowers relative to
other graph graph databases is the
cipher query language we're going to
talk a lot about that and why that is so
important let's talk about it right now
graph query yes sure posed opponent now
for G how does it compare it was the
graphical uiju sequel server that was
recently introduced in Miss Kosmos DB
which also supports graph using
different query language maybe you know
I have a very specific answer for that
but it's coming a little bit later can I
can I park that question and return to
it okay because that kind of gets into I
mean the the really short answer is if
you have a graph abstraction you can
kind of sorta do graphs either way but
the underlying implementation matters a
lot in terms of your performance and
scalability expectations and I hope to
talk a little bit about how that's
implemented under the covers and then
when we talk about how graphs work on
top of sequel server you'd see some
clear differences okay
I'm sorry I don't let me dodge the
question okay it's just that like if we
don't yet haven't talked about cypher
I'm going to give too much information
too soon all right
so cypher is a query is a pattern
matching query language made for graphs
now I'm a big database geek neo4j is not
the first database that I've ever worked
with I kind of love them all for
different reasons
okay and one of the things that I'm
completely unreasonable about at this
point in my career is I have to have a
declarative query language I do not want
to write code that goes and tells the
database how to fetch data I want a
declarative language where I express
what I want and then it's the databases
job to go figure out what's the best
query execution plan to go do that now
if you guys have been using sequel
forever and most people have you're used
to this all right you just Express what
you want and you don't think about which
index gets used first or anything like
that like this is an extremely powerful
thing and yet some of the newer no SQL
databases have trained us to go do with
less than that right and so this is the
point where I'm going to be unreasonable
you need a declarative query language if
you're going to work on
serious database and cipher is is that
for grasp did you have question online
just let you know there's a little delay
so there's no special maybe a little bit
delayed but smooth is asking does New
York or day support grab strings I would
ask the questioner to clarify that so
yes in the sense that you can ask a
query and the result can be a stream of
things that you process as it comes back
but I'm not sure if I'm getting to what
the questioner is asking so cipher is a
pattern matching query language made for
graphs
it's declarative hopefully I've already
convinced you that that's a really good
thing it's expressive and it's focused
on pattern matching now if you remember
the whiteboard friendliness point you
can probably follow why pattern matching
is important we want to be able to write
a query fluently as we think about how
the data is structured so here's a
pattern in our graph model we've got dan
loves and two nodes in a relationship
what does that look like in cypher it
looks like this a person named dan loves
a person named and I mean you can read
it from left to right and it almost
looks like the actual pattern in the
graph so this colon person is how we
tell cypher we're talking about a label
the brackets is how we talk about that
property map that we wanted right so
name equals Dan loves person and labels
and properties you'll notice that in the
round brackets parenthesis if you're
American are nodes so when we when we
ask to create a pattern we can do the
same thing with labels properties and
relationships so we can create an entire
pattern in the database just by that by
like visually describing it and just
saying hey go go make me one of those we
can also match and we can create these
variables okay so a person named dan
loves whom returned whom that's you guys
probably don't have a whole lot of site
for experience but everybody ought to be
able to tell me what that query does all
right all right great
so we've got two nodes and in the second
case we're creating a match to a
variable on the second node and then
we're just returning what that variable
should be bound to as a result of what's
in the database so let's let's look at a
social recommendation query example this
is our vp of product his name is philip
and here's one of our product managers
named andreas and this guy he's amazing
I hope you run into him someday his name
is Michael hunger so these guys are
friends and they like certain sushi
restaurants so I sushi serve sushi sushi
Sam serve sushi
they're both located in New York Philip
Rath Lee here finds himself searching
for sushi restaurants in New York that
my friends like frequently a lot of
these social recommendation type
questions can be phrased as a graph path
and so how you would answer that in
cypher would look like this so I'm
looking for a person who is a friend of
somebody else that friend likes a
restaurant that restaurant is located in
a certain location and it serves a
certain type of cuisine and the the
variable bindings that our user has
given us is that the person's name is
Philip we're talking about New York and
he's interested in sushi and so these
graph patterns with a couple of
variables thrown in and get get used to
drive the social recommendation okay so
before the colon is the name of a
variable that's being bound after the
colon is the label okay
yes I mean there's the label on the node
right so schema right so we say so we
talked a little bit earlier about how
nodes can have a label and that's sort
of like the semantic category of
information it is so this node
represents a person and this person
whoever wrote the query chose the
variable name person so it looks a
little bit misleading right but the
lowercase person is the name of a
variable and then the uppercase P is the
the label it basically what we're saying
is whatever gets matched to this
variable must be labeled person does
that make sense
the no it has multiple des Vosges then
it will match it has two it will match
to if it's labeled both person and enemy
it's still a person those properties
what was that yes they're their
properties um so when the data was
created this node got created with that
property and so basically this is
placing a constraint that the only
persons who can match are those having a
name property whose value is filip okay
clarification I'm sure if you want to
jump back so you're going back to the
business if does it support streams
uh-huh you're asking basically streams
to small perhaps like syntactic
structure of sentences or the scrap you
come from Twitter for instance and a use
case would be extracting significant
patters in real-time
ooh okay um yeah there's so many ways I
could go with that question google neo4j
and NLP I wrote this long medium article
about natural language processing with
neo4j and that that one link which I
can't go into that for time reasons
right now has a lot of information on
this topic on the streaming thing the
person can also google neo4j streams and
there's a Kafka integration that talks
about producing transactions as a stream
or consuming streams from Kafka and
putting them into a graph and and so
hopefully that's going to help without
going too deep
okay so in our earlier example we had a
really tiny graph now imagine this
happens in a super massive graph and you
have hundreds and thousands of friends
basically what these queries are doing
is they're finding the best starting
points and then they're traversing
through the graph from those starting
points declarative query for graphs
sometimes our developer relations people
find these things that people said on
Twitter and that's like particularly
emblematic like we couldn't have said it
better if we had our own marketing
people do it so they cap these things
and then keep them what I learned in
neo4j training today is that you draw
ASCII art to code so how true is that
nodes are drawn with parenthesis
relationships are drawn with arrows with
additional details and brackets patterns
you connect nodes and relationships with
hyphens and optionally specifying
Direction now you'll notice this is a
this is a relationship going one way
this is the same going the opposite way
you can traverse it undirected this is
saying you know either way right it'll
match either way but the components of a
cipher query basically look a lot like
sequel just with adaptations so match
and return our keywords mmm as a
variable movie is a node label we
actually covered that just a moment ago
about how to tell what's the variable
and and and what is the type of
information you're trying to match in
this particular query PR and M are
variables notice that we can bind
relationships too and we can return them
as first class types and we can specify
that a relationship we want to traverse
must be the acted in relationship so
yeah this is pretty straightforward the
only addition here is that sometimes
what we want to match is not the node
and not the relationship but the path
itself so in this case what we're doing
is we're drawing a pattern we're
assigning that to a path and then we're
returning the path we have a host of
built-in functions that allow you to
manipulate paths so for example you can
most how long it is
you can ask which node is
the third position so on and so forth so
graph versus tabular results if you do
match M movie return M okay basically
what you're going to get back is a node
if you do return M title m dot release
you're going to get a data square and
it's going to be a table just like any
other write properties get accessed by
saying variable dot property name so in
this way you can return graph components
paths relationships nodes or you can
just return tables of information much
as you would with sequel not terribly
interesting is moving quickly through
this cipher key words are always case
insensitive and node labels relationship
types and property keys are always case
sensitive so you know match on the right
with funky capitalization is fine and
acted in is always strictly all
uppercase with an underscore in between
no exceptions
so aggregates in cipher they're a little
bit different we never need to specify a
grouping key and so in sequel you have
this group by a concept that does not
exist in in cipher we always group by
any non aggregate keys in the return
statement so if for example you did this
give me all the movies that this person
acted in you're gonna aggravate that by
the individual actors name notice
there's no group by statement here
that's a thing we want to pull out this
this is something that often trips
people coming from sequel going to
cipher is there like how do I do group
by and the answer is you don't there's a
bunch of different aggregate functions
at the at the very back of the
presentation at the end I'm gonna give a
lot of different links and resources
there's a thing out there called the
cipher ref card if you google cipher ref
card it is kind of like the one page
cheat sheet of everything you could
possibly want to know about cipher
it's the 90% solution to most of my
problems when I'm working with cypher
talk a little bit about constraints and
indexes now and neo4j doesn't have
formal schemas as such
but we do support a lot of different
kinds of constraints and indexes we can
create unique constraints basically
these allow really fast lookup of nodes
that match by properties and this is how
you would do that in fairly
straightforward English create
constraint on label assert that a
certain property is unique and so in
much the same way as you create a
primary key this is how you would do
roughly the equivalent in cipher oh by
the way that's unique with respect to
this label it's not globally unique in
the database it's so constraints are
always bound to a certain label so there
are three kinds of unique constraints
you have the unique node property
constraint you have the node property
existence constraint so for example if
we want to create a person we want to
always ensure for data quality that they
always have a name
can't ever have a person without a name
and we can create relationship property
existence constraints saying you know
like for example don't create a company
record in our database unless you know
who the CEO is so company is controlled
by CEO okay a company can't exist
without a CEO so in general indexes
allow fast lookup of nodes just as they
do in other databases you can create an
index like this this place is no
particular constraint on the values but
it drastically increased increases the
selectivity of queries when they execute
and this is how in declarative languages
you hint to the database how it's going
to build a plan and how it's going to
execute a query efficiently these
predicates all use indexes so when you
create those inside of neo4j two we have
a way of backing indexes differently so
you can create indexes backed by leucine
or backed by our native implementation
and there are some other options as well
so you have some flexibility with your
data types if you know more about your
data type you can choose a non-standard
index type and improve performance
so indexes are only used for finding the
starting points for queries and you'll
find this is really a pattern with graph
query overall is fundamentally we're not
scanning through millions and billions
of records and trying to filter that but
rather what we're doing is we're trying
to identify starting points and then
traverse out from that and we talked
about index free adjacency the the
operation of traversing a relationship
is fundamentally very cheap in neo4j
very fast and so that's that's why
you're going to do it this way we use
index scans to look up rows in
relational you use those index scans to
look up the rows and join and in graph
you use them just to find the starting
points and then you traverse okay so one
last tricky thing about cipher I want to
talk a little bit about before we move
on is merge merge is how many folks are
familiar with up search option you know
it up starts about this is kind of like
the equivalent of up cert okay so when
you merge it is create if it does not
exist so when we say merge P person
named Tom Hanks Oscar true so if there
is there is not a person node with named
Tom Hanks and Oscar true in the graph
but there is somebody whose name is Tom
Hanks what do you think's going to
happen here it's going to create the
node if you took off the Oscar is true
it's going to match entirely on what is
in the merge statement if that exists it
does nothing if it does not exist in its
entirety then it gets created as such so
one of the biggest stumbling points with
cipher is somebody runs a query like
this and they already had a Tom Hanks
and now they have two Tom Hanks's
alright so quickly some write queries
you know create that's pretty much as
straightforward as it gets right okay
we're gonna create Mystic River 2003
alright what we can also do is if we
wanted to modify that but we didn't
actually want to create the record we
can match it and then set its tagline
to be this famous quote from the movie I
think I've got some co-workers who were
real nuts for Mystic River
I was lobbying for a matrix example but
they went with matrix who with with
Mystic River okay absolutely
okay so what if we wanted to create a
relationship between two existing nodes
well we would match them both
we've got Kevin Bacon we've got Mystic
River and then we would simply create a
relationship between them now you'll
notice on either end of that
relationship we're using a variable
which is already bound to something so
we're not saying create a node okay that
results in only the creation of the
relationship and what we return from
that is PRM the the whole all three
components so we've got the merged
person Tom Hanks example with just the
name versus with Oscar equals true
suppose you wanted to make sure Tom
Hanks got an Oscar but you didn't know
whether he already existed or not then
what you would do is you would merge
just Tom Hanks guaranteeing that it
would not create one if he already
exists and then you would set P Oscar
equals true this would be the way that
you can get only the Tom Hanks and also
modify him at the same time yes in the
scenario if the loss of a car with both
parts and also a crystal already in the
database will display the second pompons
node no it would not this would in the
met in the merge it would not create it
because there's one already existing
that one existing would be bound to the
variable P and then in the next Clause
the the peas Oscar property would be set
to the value true so this is this is
shown specifically to illustrate the
difference in merge semantics between
create the bottom line is that merge
merge checks everything that you give it
and so you want to merge only on your
key values if that makes sense and then
set anything else and in this way you
can do what you want to do
between this much video so okay that's
kind of that's though what I'm trying to
illustrate so in this is the first merge
and this is the second merge okay in
this merge what we're telling cipher is
go find me a person who has named Tom
Hanks and who has Oscar true if such a
thing does not exist create it okay
that'll work that'll always work but if
there is just a Tom Hanks who does not
have an Oscar property
okay then you'll end up with two Tom
Hanks in your database make sense even
with merge because you specified that
you only were looking for a Tom Hanks
where Oscar is true if you do it this
way it will look to see if there's any
Tom Hanks irrespective of whether or not
he has an Oscar property okay it'll find
that Tom Hanks and then it only ensure
that whoever that guy is he's got an
Oscar makes sense in this scenario you
will end up with one Tom Hanks okay III
point this out because this is a common
stumbling block about merge semantics
that is usually pretty easy to explain
but folks need to know how that works um
so merge also has these other two
options you can do on create and on
match so for example if it mattered to
you whether he was new or not um then
you could say on create give him a
timestamp of when he was created and
specify that you know as of his time of
creation he's never been updated but if
you actually matched him okay then you
don't want to update the created
timestamp because you didn't just create
him just now but instead you want to
increment his updated counter okay and
in this way you can the cypher planner
will tell you whether or not it actually
gave you something that already existed
or whether it created something as a
result of the merge okay before we go on
the data import any other like broad
questions about cypher yes if you have
relationships
and notes of the same thing absolutely
if I'm saying if you say create and then
you give it a pattern that has any
number of nodes and relationships it's
going to create all of them at the same
time in the same transactions yeah yes
sir so a mini example of saying that
person love movie right return so what
do you prefer a label for a person
they're multiple like topics and for
maybe the same name of the movie you
know occur several times in this case
we'll do return um
suppose there were say three Tom Hanks's
or three mystic rivers they all of three
will be with the same name yeah in this
case your variable would be bound to
three different instances and then if
for example you said set the property on
this variable you'd be setting it across
all three words when we can get on query
just return it without the same thing if
you just did match person named Tom
Hanks and there were actually three then
that variable would be bound to three
different notes and so if if in the next
clause you then set the property Oscar
equals true it's going to get set on all
three so okay so I see so so it was a
for example person love movie movie
names show up seven times and the person
name like there are say that notes and
then there will be a five times seven
redoubts return because in each of them
each each pair of them will form this
love relationship mm-hmm yes that that's
possible depending on what the what the
data in your graph is but we need to get
to a more particular example there so it
it's like what you're asking about is a
Cartesian product I mean there are many
ways because you're talking about Rao
talk about route there are many ways to
organize readouts yeah so I'm asking
which way do you choose to organize the
results you know I I'm not trying to
dodge the question but it just depends
on what what you want out of the
database right so you can problem the
problem I can you need to be infer what
I want right I'm gonna say person love
something what
oh there's there's no there's no
inference that's happening right you you
the database is going to give you
exactly what you asked for but you you
know you need some practice with cipher
to specify precisely what you're looking
for so usually that's where you kind of
go back to what I said earlier which is
you identify the starting points in your
graph like person named Tom Hanks and
then you traverse out from that it's
possible to create Cartesian products
using cipher but you don't usually want
to do that it's like you can't really
avoid ambiguity in the data for example
the same table will always show up a lot
of the times you know no matter it's
personal in movies right so in this case
whether it's a precise language you know
well if you find language about you deal
with this situation what I can say is
I've worked with cypher for a couple of
years and I have not run into a
situation where I could not avoid
ambiguity I would welcome a concrete
example of that and then maybe we could
work through how to reformulate the
query now it is possible to express
ambiguous queries but you know I believe
that that's true of most query languages
and I think we would really focus on
tuning the data model and tuning the
query to get to specifics I'm not saying
it's not possible I'm just saying if
that's difficult don't do it that way
you know um yes he's going back it's
comment your previous names Tom hanger
again if they're late from the other
side I think you may as I said where if
you get more than one match thanks not
that it didn't exist that you got more
than one so in this particular batch or
merge or did they mess right okay so if
if you use the match keyword then the
variable gets bound to as many of them
as there are if you use the merge
keyword you're basically saying get or
create okay and so if you say get or
create then it's going to end up being
one so if it actually found mostly us we
shouldn't find awful
I was hanging right okay that's it yeah
yes sir and it's all like here the names
that I could be used us that I did to
keep us reviews of the yes of the yes is
there the three ways to enforce like
uniqueness of identity yes absolutely we
covered that a bit earlier that's in the
unique if I can back up to uniqueness
property constraints so there you would
say yeah you want to create a where is
it
create constraint on person assert label
dot name is unique and then in this way
if you attempted to insert a second Tom
Hanks it would fail okay so I mean in
much it's it's really the same as you do
it in many other databases there all
right let's see moving forward okay
so data import there are there are so
many different options of loading data
into neo4j I can't really cover them all
so we chose to focus on one one of the
most common one of the simplest that
people use the most frequently called
load CSV it lets you take a CSV file
from HTTP or file URL gives you a stream
of Records and then basically pipes
those stream of records into a
subsequent cipher query which you can
use to create and update graph
structures it gives you transactional
operations so whenever you do load CSV
it's happening in the context of a big
transaction you can transform and
convert stuff as you go and it's it's a
primary way that when people are getting
started they they insert data into neo4j
it works up to say ten million or so
nodes and relationships um because it's
transactionally bound if you wanted to
put let's say oh i don't know 20
gigabytes of data into a graph you
wouldn't want the overhead of
transactions and you would use a
separate tool called neo4j import but
for simplicity we want to talk about
load CSV as a simple way to get started
let's take an example
sticking with the movies theme
we have a simple movie CSV file
hopefully this is pretty
self-explanatory titles release and
taglines we have a people CSV file that
just gives us a name and when they were
born we have some actors you'll notice
movies roles in person so this is like
implicitly telling us about an edge in
our graph alright or a relationship that
this person was in this movie and then
you have some directors so recalling our
data model a person acts in a movie a
person can also direct a movie because
remember they can be an actor or
director so for every record in the file
we want to either create a node for a
person or a movie we want to find a
start and end node and then create a
relationship between them so we covered
those in the basic sections earlier
about how that works and that's the
creating of the relationship at the
bottom so how do we actually read the
CSV with cipher using periodic commit
basically says batch this up into
smaller transactions so we don't like
pull in a hundred megabytes and then do
all that all at once load CSV is pretty
straightforward with headers tells us
that the first line of that CSV will
give us metadata from URL pretty
straightforward we're gonna call
whatever that stream of Records coming
back is we're going to call those rows
and we're going to specify that it's
semicolon delimited it's not comma
delimited data and then that big sigh
first thing that I showed you on the
previous slide where we're doing all
that match and create comes later and so
basically now this variable row is bound
and we can create graph patterns with
the content of row row will have you
know if it's the movie CSV file row will
have a title attribute that we can use
yes sorry about some packaging so
somebody's asking a certain about wonky
no there is not because okay so that's a
that's a fantastic question a foreign
key in a relational database is a key to
somebody else's table and we put that so
that we can do a joint okay there are no
joins in u4j there's only a relationship
traversal and so foreign keys have no
purpose okay it if I saw a person
writing a cipher query where they were
putting a foreign key on a node and then
they were trying to match a bunch of
other nodes where its ID was equal to
this foreign key that they saw that they
had on this other node oh man that would
that would be a person who's working
really hard to you know that's a person
who's really trying to defeat the model
too so that they can work too hard so
but the short answer is no there's
really no no foreign key in their
projection um related to this load CSV
stuff so in our browser we have this
cool function where you can type in coal
and play and then give it a URL and
it'll step you through a nice guide on
how to use some of these features so
this is how to do to go through a mini
class on importing data in cipher and
it's going to step you through the same
example that I showed but it's going to
make it interactive and executable for
you in the browser
developing apps so we have ap is for
most of the popular languages when you
talk to a database over the wire you're
using a binary protocol we call bolt we
support go Java Python JavaScript and a
number of others we also have community
support for a bunch of other languages
are I mean all kinds of different things
there is a cypher transactional HTTP
endpoint so you can talk to near 4j over
HTTP we generally recommend that people
use bolt much as you would use JDBC for
a relational database there's a link to
language guides where you can get really
simple just bootstrap me and get me
started quickly with Python type code
examples we have a native Java API as
well where you can actually launch neo4j
in memory and you can use the java api
to define user defined procedures
and access the core API so the way that
you extend neo4j itself is typically in
Java neo4j is written in Java and you
can extend the cypher language by
writing your own functions and procedure
as much as you can and in other
databases
Boult high-performance its versioned
it's based on PAC stream supports TLS
and it also does a lot of connection
pooling type stuff so if you're talking
to a neo4j cluster you would like to
talk to just the cluster and not worry
about whether you're talking to node a
or node B and that is called bolt plus
routing and so there's a way that you
can set your client app up to use a bolt
plus routing driver to a cluster and
it'll worry about you know routing the
the query to the right server
automatically for you so you just ask a
question get an answer or forget the
cluster topology you can extend cipher
with user-defined procedures we mostly
don't recommend people do this until
they have exhausted the the other
options with cipher so you can get
really far by reformulating your cipher
query or by right putting the right
indexes in place sometimes you need to
access some third party API or you need
to do something extremely performance
sensitive and you can write your own
function or procedure to do that and
then call that from cipher that just
gets done with these Java annotations
they're just Java classes that are
annotated a certain way you compile this
you get a jar file you drop it into the
plugins directory and you're pretty much
done and your server has a new extension
talked a little bit about the migration
of relational to graph because this is a
really big topic for us because most
folks are used to thinking in terms of
relations relation relational it tends
to be simple until it gets complicated
you end up with all of these different
joins and how many folks here have
written one of those gigantic monster
ugly sequel queries where you're joining
like 8 9 10 tables yes yeah so you know
you know relational and not consider the
relationships themselves the way
we think about the mapping between these
two ideas is okay the the naive approach
before you optimize anything basically
think about all your tables and think
about the table name turn that into a
label and make the table a set of notes
foreign keys become relationships that's
actually apropos to the question earlier
so whenever you see a primary foreign
key linkage you need to be thinking in
my model there's a relationship they're
linked tables that are used in
relational to resolve many-to-many
mappings are basically just
relationships with extra properties
typically and then you throw out all the
the primary and foreign keys that you do
not need so sometimes you need a primary
key to look up an item by its identity
but you never need foreign keys and so
you're storing a lot less data to begin
with yes or the problem is suitable more
for a relational database or for the
database or maybe for another sequel
names yes we're getting to your section
okay so um I I can't defer that much
longer
we're get we're almost there okay so we
know how to query a relational database
we just use sequel and so we do these
joins
everybody's most people are familiar
with joints how do we create a graph
what we do is we Traverse we've we've
kind of covered this so this this is
starting to get into when do you use one
versus when you use the other okay so
our team a our DBMS is it turns out that
they actually don't handle relationships
that well because they they can't model
or store them without complexity and
what I mean by that is they're
introducing artificial extra features
like foreign keys where you are
basically propping up the formalism in
order to support this thing that you
need to do ok the performance degrades
with the number and level of
relationships and database size and we
can reason about this straightforwardly
in that joins are computed at query run
time ok so it's not that this data is
pre joined but I have to scan table a
scan table B match things up in memory
and now granted 30 years of database
research has gone into making
superfast but you still have to compute
it every single time okay
query complexity grows with the need for
more joins and as you add new kinds of
data and relationships this is where you
know you get into the kind of no sequel
thing where sequel being fundamentally
schema bound is good in the data
integrity sense and it's bad in the
evolvability and agility sense because
it tends to be inflexible it's not
terribly easy to define a new
relationship on the fly and then rewire
your graph okay so one of the things we
would say is when data relationships are
valuable in real-time traditional
databases aren't the best choice and the
reason for that is that you're going to
be recomputing these joins every single
time and you're going to be doing
typically a lot more scans of a lot more
data than is strictly necessary
we can also this this gets to when would
you use a graph and not relational
suppose your question was find all
reports and how many people they manage
up to three levels down okay so if I
could give you one slide that got me
into graph databases this would probably
be it I had this data lineage problem
where I had a directed acyclic graph of
data and the things used to derive that
and the question that I wanted to ask
was give me all reports that were
derived from information sourced by the
airforce don't care if it's two hops
back or if it's five hops back or if
it's 15 okay and oh man I spent a week
and a half becoming a sequel palette and
learning how to write recursive sequel
using stored procedures optimizing the
hell out of it not getting very far with
it and so basically I went up the
mountain and I consulted with the sequel
gods and I got the absolute best advice
all right and in the end it still was
terrible okay so one of our field
engineers I think they took this yeah
this is an example from a previous
customer who ended up coming to the dark
side of graphs on anyway somebody
actually wrote this query like I wish I
could zoom in I mean I don't want to
waste you guys time by reading this
thing to you but it's a real query okay
and there it isn't sequel and there it
is in cypher now
the magic here in cypher is that we can
specify a variable number of
relationship hops that we want to we
want to traverse okay
earlier on I said that traversing a
relationship is fundamentally cheap and
very performant in neo4j because of the
way it's set up and we're about to get
to how that works but here one line of
cipher with some simple constraints and
a return Clause gets rid of this much
sequel why because the question and the
data is fundamentally graphi so when you
take a fundamentally graphic problem
domain and you put it into tables
typically pain results now if you had a
fundamentally table based problem where
you said I have an entry I just have a
customer list of 300 million customers
and all I ever want to do is pull out
which ones are in this particular zip
code relational has been optimized for
30 years to do that well and I'm not
going to try to convince you that that's
fundamentally graphi ok but if your
problem is fundamentally graphi I think
we can get there does it um so why graph
this is basically about modeling your
data naturally driving the graph model
from the domain and from the use cases
rather than from your college textbooks
that tell you how you need to have it in
third normal form in order to reduce
redundancy whenever you need to use a
relationship information in real time
and whenever you need this flexibility
to add relationships on-the-fly you're
probably in the grass sweet spot so
relationships are a first-class citizen
and what we mean by that is the entire
database is focused around relationships
and traversing those right so it's not
something that you tack on with scans
and with foreign keys and with primary
keys it's just baked in a you know an
interesting way that I've heard in your
for Jay described is imagine if your
database had all of its joins pre
materialized like they had been pre
computed once ok then your your most of
the way to a graph database we have
query and data look
part of the way that we can be faster is
that we identify the starting points and
move out from them rather than doing
these massive scans only load what's
needed aggregate and project as you go
and then optimize disk and memory model
for graphs so I'm gonna get to the index
tree adjacency here in a second if you
have a social graph with a thousand
people and you average 50 friends per
person you end up with this densely
connected graph and if you ask is there
a path from five odd to myself in this
social graph but I never want to go
deeper than four hops okay first of all
before we talk about performance can we
agree that that's a really ugly sequel
query that's very difficult to write
okay let's say we warm up the cache and
we eliminate a disk i/o for both
databases these are the observed values
okay and it makes sense if you think
about how these databases are built and
that it is a fundamentally graphi
problem this shouldn't be surprising or
a hollow marketing claim okay
so this is the secret sauce this is how
it works and this is why I'm asking you
to believe that this is very much a more
performant database and it's not just
marketing so inside of the database we
use pointer pointers instead of lookups
and so when you have a relationship it
has a pointer on either end to the place
in memory you need to go to find that
note okay so when you traverse a
relationship it does not scan all the
nodes and figure out what's connected
all right second is we have fixed size
records and if you know much about disk
IO that allows us to rip through a whole
lot very quickly and to be able to do
offset jumps and index seeks extremely
efficiently joins on creation this is
what I meant by pre materializing your
join okay relational database is
computing it every single time on the
fly we computed it once when you wrote
the data and then never again
so there's fundamentally a computational
cost that we don't have to pay every
time you traverse the edge and
essentially the secret sauce is that you
just spin spin spin through that data
structure over and over and over again
and that is why traversing relationships
is cheap because it's pointer
dereferencing in the end
so if we know that this whole concept
the secret sauce so to speak online
you'll hear us talk about this as index
free adjacency and so there are articles
you can look up on index free adjacency
but this is really what's meant and so
when we say that the secret sauce is
index free adjacency this is why we are
claiming that relational can't respond
sub second for n way joins and that why
we claim that relational is not agile is
because it requires changes to queries
in these new data feeds now back to your
question you were asking about sequel
server and so hopefully I've given kind
of an overview about that cosmos is a
completely different story because it's
unrolling architecture is different but
you'd kind of see how it structures its
data differently as well this was not
relation as far as I understand graph
community groups I'm not sure what
services they were the end of there I'm
not familiar was that part of it but
it's not a relational it's supposed to
be like pure drop something are you
familiar was that to me I'm
unfortunately not I'd love to take a
look at though okay it was added later
recently at least I notice of like a
months ago I'm not sure but it's it
iodide another 17 yeah I notice it like
Iran's ago maybe it was that yeah so
there is something that when it comes to
cosmos DB cosmos DB has a way to look at
the data as a graph and I believe in
sports clearing as gremlin yeah yes
that's right but to kind of see how
never 4j compares to cosmos especially
when it comes to performance in the case
for nodes would have huge number of
relationships any conduct yeah millions
relationship and there's in the bus that
I was trying to use now for Jake what
they're learning is that now G does not
scale out especially that you can have
as
system was cluster which is a very two
or three or several beefy machines with
lots of memory and that's all you can
have and if you want to add more data
essentially you will hit the wall okay
is just funny thing changed from the
time I looked at now on 4 June 2014 so
you had like three or four different
things I need to unpack there so the
first is the super node pattern which is
the idea of a node having hundreds or
thousands of connections ok
it is it is true that super nodes in
general within all graph databases are
considered an anti-pattern now most of
the time when we run into customers who
have this problem the the problem is
somewhere in the modeling layer and so
you may wish to make a compromise such
that you do not end up with nodes with
this crazy degree now sometimes the
problem can be reduced in another way so
it matters a lot for example whether the
node has 200,000 out edges of the same
type or whether they're of different
types because that of course affects
selectivity in the database right so in
general I wouldn't recommend a modeling
approach that ends you up with hundreds
of thousands of links per per node okay
and I think you'll find that common to a
lot of the graph databases now on the
gremlin point so comparatively between
neo4j and cipher I've used cipher and
I've also used gremlin the I was kind of
beating on this point about declarative
graph query languages earlier in in part
because of gremlin gremlin has a very
imperative feel to it it has some
declarative features but in generally
you're telling it how to traverse things
we find this pretty brittle and so one
of the things that you're going to find
with gremlin after you use it for an
extensive period of time is that as your
data structure changes you're going to
have to go back and rewrite your queries
because you told it which way to
traverse and then that structure has
changed right you're also going to find
yourself optimizing the queries for the
database and so you can do graph query
with gremlin
I just find it
to be a lot more difficult sometimes
less performant and less maintainable as
well alright and there was a third point
I think I'm forgetting scale I know
about scaling out right so the
scalability picture is still similar to
what you remember the way that I would
describe scalability in neo4j is that
our cluster architecture has a leader
and followers you get vertical
scalability for rights and you get
horizontal scalability for reads okay
what that means is to guarantee all the
acid properties you have one leader
whenever you do a write it has to be
processed through that leader so you
probably can't process more rights than
one leader can handle and so you can
scale that reader that that leader up
okay if you want to scale the graph out
you have the option to add read replicas
and additional followers to your cluster
so there's functionally unlimited
scalability for read queries out okay
we covered this so Ambrose we're gonna
get into learning resources we want to
start some demos and begin with with
Ambrose and then I'll show some extra
stuff come on down alright so my name is
Ambrose I'm from the Services pentest
team of CDG and today I'm just gonna
show you like a ten minute demo of how
to import data from CSV into a neo4j
graph and without using cipher so it's a
little bit more intuitive let me quickly
show you what problem we just deal with
so during the reconnaissance phase of
our pen tests we want to you know we
have lots of data from different tools
here on the Left we have a direct report
to a manager right and on the right we
have those aliases math - what file they
recently opened so that's from the delve
tool output ok so the thing we want to
do is pretty much just combine them and
see what it looks like in the graph okay
so I created a little like helper
library console application that will
make it a little bit more intuitive for
you to import data so let's take a look
at importing the management data here so
the CSV looks something like this and in
my like little language thing that I
made here pretty much you have to define
some metadata about that CSV file
so what knows do you want to create so
here I'm saying I want to create a
manager node from that first column and
then I want to create a report node the
direct report and then at the bottom
here you specify the relationship which
is manager which is this manager the
relationship name which is manager of
and then you know the second node which
is report and then here I have the
properties so the ID would be manager
the name is manager label which is
type is ms alias so I'm just gonna run
this real quick I'll show you what that
looks like wait hold on let me make sure
that the graph is clear so this is what
it looks like at the end I'm going to
delete it so here I have neo4j running
locally on my laptop okay
so I'm gonna run the important manager
on this and then you'll see that it's
going to take that CSV file and then
load it up over here okay so here I have
the labels and you know names
applied to these nodes okay so like
later on we might get some more data
about these people right so I'm going to
import the second set of data which is
the Delft data about what file they
recently opened and then we're gonna see
what that looks like yeah for Delft data
down here so in this case I made my
helper tool merge on the merge on the
node IDs so if it sees a you know the
user with the same like username it's
going to use that node instead of
creating a separate node so in this case
I'm going to ID the the files by the URL
and then the users are just ID by
username like they were before and the
relationship is user and then worked on
file so I'm going to run this report no
data
okay refresh it now expand it here so
then you can see that you know you can
see which are the common files that two
users I've opened and this is much
easier to see then like looking at CSV
files alright and yeah and then I guess
you can create you know whatever you
know cipher queries you want to you know
traverse this graph if you want but this
solves the initial hurdle of you know
getting some you know a CSV data into a
graph format all right and one last
thing this is I wrote the tool here so
you can find AKMs slash CSV to graph and
you can you know download the console
application version of this which is
it's pretty much the same you just run
it like this you pass it a JSON config
file and then in jet in that JSON config
file it looks something similar like
this so you pretty much say which folder
you want to use and then you know CSV
files with name direct reports will have
this metadata which is similar to what I
showed you before and then CSV files
with you know Delft would have this
metadata and this tells how to you know
create the neo4j graph so underneath the
hood I do call cipher queries but like
if you're just learning this for the
first time it may be easier to just you
know just define the properties like a
like like so here yeah so essentially
the library I wrote you know it doesn't
necessarily have to be a CSV it just has
to be a just some kind of this just has
to be an inner opal this thing right it
doesn't have to be CSV so maybe you can
connect to a sequel database or
something and then get your objects in
the list and then you know import it
that way
so yeah both the library in the console
app are located
yeah so it's probably the least
technical person in this room that was
super impressive
and that's super intimidating so David
why would I choose to do this method for
you seeis being it to me over Jay as
opposed to the standard built-in Corey
you're safe um let me ask a question
before I before I answer that so did you
read the read the files line by line and
then create use like create an emerge or
did you take the data from the user and
then run load CSV in your code no I
didn't run it's better bundled CS me
okay custom yeah well so a really good
reason why you would want to not use
lewin CSV would be for example if you
needed to do something in your
programming language that was well
supported in your programming language
but it wasn't in cipher so I've seen
users do stuff for example maybe you get
some addresses and you want to run them
through Google's geocoding API and which
one put into your graph is latitude and
longitude okay you can't call the
geocoding API from Seifer but you can do
that in a c-sharp program that would be
a good reason right another is that you
may know more about the form of the data
and you need a really high-performance
insert so you might choose for example
like load CSV will say batch 500 records
at once but if you're doing a zillion of
these you might want to batch them in a
particular way for performance reasons
you know but I think the biggest reason
would probably be programming language
specific features where you're not
really just loading data but you're
transforming or enriching or cleaning or
doing something else with it yeah so
like load CSV is a pure cipher solution
so you can do anything with that that
you can do a cipher but start first on a
general-purpose programming language so
it's a graph query language Oh sometimes
that makes more sense so they get that
mean that really gets back to you the
core question of what probably
resolvable question try to answer yeah
well you know this big technology
there's always 15 ways different ways to
do this I think and I did not
necessarily wrong yeah um do you think
if I'd asked you like in your learning
curve when you first got started in your
future
can you recall anything about it just
for people who are new that that you
particularly liked or thought was good
or sticking points where you
particularly had problems or didn't
understand concept I found that querying
by relationships really helpful the fact
that you can just like you know I just
like the you know the querying like you
had different levels you can create down
three levels that was good what when I
didn't like too much is about because
around like creating nodes because it's
kind of awkward you don't you don't
really create nodes much when you're
using the new forge a graph right so
like every time I need to create
something I kind of like had to
reference back so that's kind of why I
created this helper tool so I don't have
to remember what the syntax was for
creating stuff so yeah that's not
something half of what engineers do for
a living is automate away the the paint
and the problems that they have so um I
mean that that's really cool I the
question is so you have this graph right
and you can put all the CSV in it have
you guys looked at any kind of analyses
that you might do on top of that so it
sounds like your use case is
fundamentally like analysis if we know
all these people in this department are
looking at these documents did you ever
have you looked into like what are the
top three most influential things that
that are the most widely read or you
could say like if you knew who wrote
these documents you could say internally
who are the top five most read authors
at Microsoft yeah those are good
questions we haven't really figured out
what the exact query is for that but
David Baldacci or Stephen King with
Microsoft probably lovers
so yeah that's pretty much my demo you
can get it at that URL and just feel
free to reach out to me if you have any
issues thank you
alright so I'm gonna take you through a
couple of different demo related things
we're gonna talk a little bit about
tooling and sort of show you how the
software actually works just before we
begin as I said this is on the azure
marketplace and so when I showed up
today I deployed a three node cluster
here it is I've got my coordinates set
got all my Azure resources I can show
you logging into this later and show you
how the cluster topology works but
basically anybody can do this you go to
the marketplace right here and I type in
neo4j and we get lots of different
options
3.5 dot 1 is the latest so neo4j
Enterprise is a single node setup where
you're going to get one machine and
causal cluster is a multi node cluster
setup and so if you're just looking to
play you do not need three VMs to do
that or nine or 15 it depends on how you
want to scale but near Frechette
Enterprise will do if you want the high
availability guarantees then you would
go for causal cluster 3.5 dot one right
there and launch that so quickly I want
to show you this tool this is called
neo4j desktop and so inside of neo4j
desktop you can create lots of local
graphs and have multiple instances of
the database running just on your
machine if you don't want the cloud
setup so here I've got a Microsoft demo
graph which I'm going to start right now
and inside of neo4j desktop you get
these things called graph apps these
little tiles up here at the top are
applications that you can run against a
neo4j graph and so what Ambrose was
showing earlier is this application here
called neo4j browser and this is kind of
like a lot of the times when users first
come to near 4 J this is their first
point of entry really it's just a cipher
command executions shell with some
graphic stuff built on top of it so I
saw him execute this query we're gonna
do the same thing on on mine you're
gonna be shocked to learn that I have
movie data in my demo set for today and
so I've got this big graph right you
this tool will allow you to for example
select nodes and I can for example
change the colors of all of them and I
can change how they're captioned and you
know make some nodes bigger than others
and so on and so forth it's a
force-directed layout but basically it
is a command shell you can run queries
and then capture CSV directly as a
result of this one thing if you're
playing with this I would recommend that
you check out the play command colon
play it will run in browser guides where
you can do learning and examples and
tutorials so for example a lot of the
stuff that I've shown you today if you
do play movies and then hit enter it
will step you through a little guide
we're not going to do this right now but
this is what the guide looks like it'll
tell you how to create this graph and
you'll see these all play buttons I can
click on the play button and it'll
automatically insert that so as they
step through the tutorial I can execute
stuff and start to play really quickly
alright so that is kind of neo4j browser
I'm gonna keep a picture of my graph up
because we might need to compare it when
we look at some of this other stuff we
also have this tool called bloom bloom
is for exploratory visualization so
whereas browser is kind of for command
execution run cipher get a result see
the trouble with that is that you have
for no cipher and you have to be kind of
a data engineering sort bloom is a more
natural language focused tool with
better visualization where you're going
to start in a particular point not
execute an analytic query which
looking for patterns you're looking to
identify bigger issues so I can say for
example person named Tom Hanks and
you'll see that it interprets that as a
graph pattern it thinks what I mean is
match a person with the name property
Tom Hanks that is what I mean here's Tom
let's command e to expand him and we
blow out just his immediate hops and
then we might say ooh you've got mail
was not a great movie let's skip that
one
oh let's see what was a great movie Oh
Joe versus the volcano everybody anybody
seen that that's some knowing laughs
back there
all right so Joe versus a vote it's
about a man who gets convinced that he
has this fake brain condition and he's
going to jump into a book anyway I can't
I can't go into that but let's expand
Joe versus the volcano because it's a
funny movie
we've got nathan lane john patrick
stanley and meg ryan who were in that
movie they're all connected to Joe
versus a volcano and now let's say we
want to just we can then explore further
and say I happen to know that meg Ryan
was also and you've got mail so if I
expand meg Ryan look at that
Sleepless in Seattle pops up as a movie
they were both in and you've got mail so
we can sort of see the commonalities
let's pick Tom Meg and you've got mail
and dismiss everybody else and then
refocus so this kind of GUI is basically
meant to do these kinds of exploratory
visualizations a lot of our financial
clients for example they might have an
idea of how fraud is happening within a
financial graph but not really be able
to quite nail it and so you can use this
for hypothesis exploration where you say
I think this is the pattern that's
happening now let me go look for
evidence of that and then rinse lather
repeat to build an overall picture of
how the network works
you know as Ambrose said earlier it's
just so much easier to actually see this
data as a graph sometimes that it spurs
a lot of discovery in that way so that's
that's kind of a quick overview of Blum
we also have a graph app here called
Halon which is for monitoring let's
actually let's close this one and do
instead our cloud instance see if we can
get that working here inside of neo4j
desktop I've got the second tile as your
deploy that is this deploy that I set up
at the very beginning of the meeting and
I'm going to activate this as a remote
database not running on my machine and
I'm gonna open my little Halon graph app
and what I'm gonna see here is a lot of
operational metrics about a multi node
cluster so along the top you'll see
these three IP addresses are the the
machines that are participating in my
cluster the one with the little star is
the leader of the cluster that takes all
the rights and the other two are
followers and basically this is this is
a rather in-depth program we're not
going to go all the way through it but
you can hover here and you can sort of
see it's got this green status
everything's looking good that's because
it's basically not doing anything right
now the cluster is idle and then we can
look at individual machines and for
example take a look at what the the
memory or the disk on this machine is
doing what plugins do we have installed
and how is it configured so for example
I can type in here whoops I can see what
addresses it is advertising to the
broader Network one last thing about
Halen is in the Diagnostics tab you can
run Diagnostics and it will gather a lot
of information about your cluster and
give you recommendations on what looks
good what might be misconfigured what
you might want to look into and this
sort of helps users diagnose some of the
most common problems associated with
configuring clusters and so on
okay so any questions about kind of like
the graph app concept we have a an API
online so that if you wanted to write
simple applications sitting on top of
neo4j this is a pretty good way to do it
in the end they're just JavaScript
programs typically with a certain
JavaScript stub API injected that allows
you to connect to and talk to the the
graph with a bolt driver instance okay
yes yes it's the same okay the only
difference here is that it's wrapped
inside of a graphic but it's the same
yes all right so that's kind of neo4j
the nickel tour of neo4j desktop let's
talk a little bit about the analytics
and data science parts I want to show
you a simple or maybe not so simple
query this is it right here
and gets to the right browser tab okay
so we bootstrapped a whole lot of
knowledge into you today about what
graphs are what cypher is how all this
stuff works we have this library that
comes packaged as a plug-in called neo4j
graph algorithms or just call it graph
outgoes for data science groups data
engineering groups really really
recommend you take a look here because
this is all of the graph e data science
stuff here that you're not going to find
in other libraries and that neo4j makes
really easy that these sorts of things
are going to be quite difficult in other
systems so the graph algorithms plug-in
is basically a compilation of a lot of
different algorithms across a lot of
different use cases this documentation
I've always thought it's pretty good
because not only does it describe like
the syntax of like how you're going to
call this or that algorithm but it also
goes into okay what is Lu veining about
and when would you use this and and you
if your problem looks like this then you
probably want PageRank instead of
something else
um some of the most fun things that I
have done working for neo4j have been
interacting with this so quick story you
know neo4j has this data journalism
outreach program where we use graph
technology work with journalists who are
doing investigations help them get
answers and then they write up the story
and publish it and when I was brand new
to neo4j I got to work with NBC News
they were doing coverage of Russian
Twitter trolls manipulating elections in
the United States and using the graph
algorithms package we loaded a whole lot
of Twitter data in that was given to us
by the sources that the journalist had
cultivated and we were looking for
community issues that is how what topics
were the troll is most frequently
talking about how did they break down a
loss certain demographic lines and all
of that social network data is
fundamentally graphi and lent itself
well to the algorithms that are in this
package getting to play with that and
doing those kinds of data analysis
is really fun primarily I was using at
the time the community detection
algorithms we were looking at all the
trolls and saying if you got rid of all
the civilians and you looked at just the
people who were involved in this
instigating behaviors who was talking to
who who was retweeting who and it turned
out that they sort of broke into
multiple communities prior to the
analysis and the publishing NBC did the
thought had been there's this big group
of trolls and they want a particular
candidate to win and that's really the
end of the story and it just wasn't at
least that's not what was in the data we
found that there were a group of trolls
who were aligned with right causes a
group of trolls aligned with left causes
and a third group and that the overall
modus operandi if you will like what
they were trying to do was more about
social division and less about
advocating for a particular person in
that election and so that that stuff got
written about in NBC News and we don't
have to go do too deep into it but for
for data scientists people I just want
you to know that like what went into
that reporting was neo4j and graph
algorithms and this is where you should
start if you want to do data analysis
with neo4j so as a simple simple example
I did a query for harmonic closeness on
my movie graph this is just computing
whoops Oh a I didn't start my database
that's that's going to help databases
are much more responsive when they're
running
so let's take a look at this query um
basically what we're getting is this
metric coming out of the harmonic
closeness algorithm the metric is
centrality I believe with this
particular algorithm the metric in and
of itself is not meaningful so it's not
like two point point two eight six means
something but magnitude and
directionality is meaningful and so this
is basically about when you look at the
graph how central is a node or how
influential is it and the overall flow
of information throughout the graph and
so the way that this query works is that
call algo de closeness harmonic that
stream and so fundamentally when we use
the call key where we're calling a
stored procedure we're giving it some
parameters where we're looking for nodes
and acted in relationships and then
basically we yield some data and then
basically match nodes in the graph that
were yielded out of this harmonic
closeness and then return whether it's a
movie or a actor we order by centrality
in descending order to find the most
central nodes first and limit to the top
20 and our buddy Tom Hanks comes out on
top and the reason for that is that when
we created this sample data set it was
all about it was centered on Tom Hanks
and we tended to add data around him
right so it's not really surprising in
this particular data set that he comes
out as very central also not surprising
is a lot of stuff that he's in shows up
being central because as we expand it
out and added to this this data set we
tended to tack on you know co-stars and
directors of the movies that he had been
in right so if for example you did this
on the entirety of Twitter you would
probably find at the center PewDiePie
Lady gaga
and all of those right because that's
who people are retweeting that's who's
sending out the most content and that's
who's reference the most often right so
um one thing I can't really do justice
in less than a full-day class is the
depth of how much is in this algorithms
stuff so basically we we kind of group
these
two families of algos if you will so
sometimes what you care about is
centrality and that's what I just showed
you
sometimes what you cared about is
community detection so I wish I had a I
kind of do have a whiteboard maybe the
cameras will follow me so sometimes if
you have a graph like this let's say you
have a graph like that
let's say your graph looks like that
totally made up but you can sort of see
that while there are a bunch of nodes
and edges there are three distinct
communities in there and so that the
family of community detection algorithms
are really trying to what they're trying
to do is give you this one two three a
lot of these algorithms as with many
machine learning algorithms and other
things that you've used they come with a
lot of tweakable and tunable parameters
right so if you fuzz it enough hey it's
all one community and if you if you make
the community stark enough then you have
as many communities as you have nodes
here right and so as with many other
algorithms that you're going to work
with there's some some tweaking and
tuning according to the domain that
you're dealing with and how specific
that you want to get but that's kind of
community detection now if you look at
this this particular graph if we ask
about the centrality of this graph you
don't really get much meaningful out of
that because there isn't really any node
with the possible exception of this guy
that's really central in this graph
right on the other hand if the pattern
that you're looking at is is sort of
like spoke and hub like this and you run
centrality a centrality type approach on
that here we can clearly see even
visually even without a fancy algorithm
what is the most central node in that
graph right and so this is where and I
know you guys know this from data
analysis it's just that the technical
features offer us all these cool
algorithms that we can run but then we
have to have a whole lot of domain
understanding of what our data is so
that we can fit this abstract math thing
that works that does something really
cool in software and then fit that to
our domain so that we know which
algorithm to use and when that is the
real art that's why we get paid the big
bucks right yes
just a use case that we're looking at we
won't actually
colors of nodes based on some
here you huh let's be a catalyst for the
graph the basic needs to be APS ah both
depending so there are path finding
algorithms that's a whole class where
that might be what you want to do it
depends on how sophisticated your paths
are sometimes what you want to do is
sort of like an iterative algorithm
where you find a path and then you set
property on that path and then you just
sort of iterate on that and then you
expand it out time and time and time
again expanding out which nodes get this
magic property each time you know what
I'm saying yeah so it kind of depends on
what you want to do but the path finding
algorithms are a help for that but in
many cases because ciphers kind of good
at that out of the box sometimes the
path finding algorithms are overkill for
that and you just need some simple
cipher can you say a little bit more
about what kind of paths do you want to
find and what meaning do they have for
you
yes actually I look on the build up your
building our clusters for as you oh okay
cool those build outs have a certain
series on jobs that happen AHA and these
jobs are the dependencies that would
need to go through as we traverse
through that and so sometimes a certain
jobs get locked or delayed then we want
to we figure the oh man so that's a
dependent yeah that's an independancy
graph so you're talking about something
like a looking arm template is that the
kind of job I mean it's Thomas
essentially you have it bust alive and
you're already doing it this is still an
ad should have been open behavior so you
got some job one that triggers job to
you know triggers job three and then you
get to this good place right yeah but
job one also triggers a four which
triggers J 5 which is needed for J 3 and
J 5 is blocked right Thank You chief
yeah yeah so um let's we'll just put a
green circle around and say job five is
blocked right so this is very similar to
like the network and IT operations use
cases where sometimes what people are
doing with graphs here is these are
routers and machines and what they want
to ask is what in this chain if it fails
we'll mess up my ability to deliver this
okay and so basically what you might
want to do is ask a query like
start-finish alright okay and then so
you want to enumerate all paths all
distinct paths from start to finish and
then you want to go through those paths
and ask if any component on that path is
blocked right that's fairly
straightforward to do a cipher right
because we know how to match a path we
know how you can use the distinct
keyword to say I want distinct paths and
then you can use functions in cipher to
pull out the nodes or you could say
match a uses I'm just making this up as
we go star B where B dot blocked true
and then this will get you P equals
returned P I'm just going really fast
hopefully this is legible you can say
match all paths where I'm going from
some starting point to some node that
note is blocked give me that path and
then you might further further this and
say B no I'm getting really small and
then say finish right
and then that right there would identify
the blocker right well yeah that's right
that's why I was thinking that
pathfinding algorithms might be
Overkill's cuz you can do this sort of
thing right and then you can sort of you
could then for example color that node
by setting the new property on it yeah
and then if you did that say every 30
seconds then separately scan what are
all of my blocked guys and and then have
some resolution approach for that does
that answer your question yes similarity
algorithms and pre-processing functions
and procedures yeah we're coming up to
the end of our time here I want to make
sure that we are respectful of
everybody's time and leave some time for
Q&A I've gone through a lot of
algorithms and a lot of stuff like I
could talk for hours about just this
piece but it gets really deep really
fast and as an intro topic I just want
to leave you with this as a point of
exploration Oh finally when you get this
is only gonna take a minute or two when
you get lost where do you go how do you
get help this is don't worry about
writing these links down or anything
like this because we're gonna distribute
a copy of the slides so all this is
going to be clickable for you everything
that I've told you today you're going to
be able to find in written documented
form out here on our developer pages we
have a graphic adam e where you can get
self-paced online training we have a
near forget j certified program where
you can go through an exam process to
get near forge a certified become a
professional and get that sweet sweet
neo4j swag right I mean this being the
techie industry I know you guys don't
have any t-shirts at all and you're
desperately in need of some and I want
you to know that we're here to help okay
so the one hour certification exam
covers a lot of the topics that we've
covered today and goes into a little bit
more depth we told you earlier about the
cypher ref card like if you only had one
link how do I do something in neo4j a
single link don't even want
whole developer manual this would be it
this is the cheat sheet of everything
that you need obviously we have
developer documentation operations
manuals for how to run clusters we have
a knowledge base as well so paying
customers get access to a lot of extra
articles we have a very large number of
public articles as well as well as
frequently asked questions
their version specific so you can find
out about how this worked in this older
version whatever you need lots of sample
applications that you can get clone
compile and go we are very passionate
about our user community and we have
regular meetups all over the world we
have a community site community neo4j
comm where you can get connected with
some of these and you can meet some of
my favorite fellow graph nerds
that's also a great point of entry to
just ask a question we have a fantastic
developer relations team that tends to
jump on helping people who are out there
and wanting to get them started and have
a good early experience with graphs you
know neo4j group grew up in the
open-source world so if you want to know
I don't know maybe you wake up late on a
Friday night you know when you should be
asleep and you say how did they
implement index tree adjacency I must go
to github and know you can do that we
have Stack Overflow
you know one of the early ways I got
involved in the community is I answered
a zillion questions out there on Stack
Overflow and so a lot of different
things that you might want to do have
already been covered books man it's
endless okay and some some colleagues
who who I have tremendous respect for we
have two people Marc Needham and Aimee
Hodler are in the process of publishing
a book on graph algorithms and so it's
going to be a very deep dive on all the
stuff that I can't cover today for for
time reasons so when that O'Reilly book
comes out I really highly recommend you
pick up a copy because bigger brains
than me I'll tell you that anyways that
brings us to Q&A I am I
I want to be here to help you have the
smoothest early process and get any of
your questions answered and please don't
spare me the hard ones UNK it in the
community has anyone attempted
algorithms which are like useful
probabilistic graphical models on neo4j
like the enforcement learning of
mandates those kind of yes I am myself
not super deep on that I'm not sure I
can answer that really thoroughly but
but yes there's a guy named Andrew
Jefferson who has written a couple of
posts on this topic and Tavian a I think
is the group that he's working with and
so that's a fairly deep rabbit hole like
how does neo4j connect to deep learning
and and a lot of those related topics
that's an area that we're increasingly
getting into there's some publishing out
there right now and there's more to come
was in the plans neo4j anything with RBI
power bi um so I think in in community
open-source there's a number of ways
that you can do that right now there is
a JDBC driver where you can write cipher
and expose a table okay there's not a
power bi specific integration that I'm
aware of but we are always you know I
work in partnerships and so on and we're
always looking to hear about what
integrations are most valuable and why
we'd love to talk to you more about that
offline so you guys are troopers it's
like five o'clock and you've been
listening to graph stuff for two hours
yes you mentioned the problem or super
nodes those worry what other problems
people are typically running into and
what are the early symptoms of oh that's
a good one and that's not amazing one
either all right okay it took me
seriously when I said ask the hard ones
okay all right um anti nodes are
definitely uh the super nodes are
definitely an anti-pattern
um near 4j does not index relationship
and or sorry relationship properties and
so an anti-pattern that I see is over
reliance on really dense property
metadata on the relationships okay so
for example if the way that you design
your model is with very thin nodes and
very fat relationships with 20 or 30
properties and then you want to write a
lot of queries that are very selective
on relationship properties this is
generally not a good idea okay that's
that's one anti-pattern
let's see super fat nodes where you
don't split things out is another
anti-pattern so recall that I've been
saying all along relationships are very
cheap to Traverse right and so let me
take a super simple example let's say
that I have a customer in a relational
database we're going to give them a name
and a state and a city let's just keep
it that simple
okay in relational databases we tend to
think about tables and so what we do is
we pile lots and lots and lots and lots
of properties on on and this breeds
queries where you're going to be
searching for all the customers who are
in the state of Virginia I'm from
Virginia so I use that as an example a
better way to do this is to take your
low dimensional categorical variables
and to break them out into nodes so for
example I would not do it this way I
would do it like this customer name has
state
has city okay so an anti-pattern
is having lots and lots of really fat
nodes and not that many relationships in
this way you are defeating what the
database does well okay and you're
falling back on your old relational scan
and filter skills does that make sense
um was there a second part to your
question that I missed or did I answer
it early symptoms early symptoms um but
bad query performance and also the early
that the other symptom would be your
graph model looks exactly the same as
your relational model that would be a
giveaway so if you have these different
affordances and different flexibilities
it ought to look at least a little
different all right it was a question
the men say yeah probably so actually
yeah um
this would help distinguish between
Richmond Virginia in Richmond California
which I can tell you are very different
places yes it's kind of awkward to like
model the times here say that in some
way this is perhaps like what's your
recommendation generally after you were
like adopt different data put based
models that great kind of thing right
yeah oh man you really can't up the
softballs for me okay so in earlier
versions of neo4j it used to be that we
recommended this time tree approach and
that's probably what you're talking
about
so in the time tree approach you would
do just for folks who have not seen the
time tree approach you would have a 2019
node linked to a January node linked to
a what is today anyway the 24th day and
then you would link that to a customer
call I don't know let's say a customer
called and this would be a time tree and
so if you wanted to find all the calls
at hand
in January you would match to the
January 2019 and then get all the notes
from their neo4j 3.4 introduced a
temporal data type so you can have times
and date times as a native data type on
a property and we have optimized indexes
for that and so when the temporal types
and temporal indexing came out we don't
do time trees anymore
you just put a date time you index it
and that's that for the same protein so
just stack that on the same for a few as
P times M so if you have a history of
values there's a different pattern for
that
so we basically you turn if part of the
problem of your domain is that you have
the customer today but you want to know
every state the customer has ever had in
the past then we're going to basically
model the customer as a linked list and
the head of the list is always so taking
our example right here and sketching it
out so you've got this customer call on
one 24:19 and then we'll have a next
link and then we'll have the same one on
one 23:19 and so on and so forth so when
when people need to do revisions and
graphs what they do is they basically
never modify the node they create a new
one with duplicate data but whatever
they need to change and the old one gets
pushed back on the linked list does that
make sense and in this way you can
traverse the chain and it's like a time
machine right you can navigate to that
node through the query and then you can
go back however many iterations you need
until you hit some time point first a
few additional was basically just to a
extra attributes that are appropriate
yes sir it's just another property it's
just another property that has the date
time datatype okay all right
yes um you know I'm let me get to your
question in just a second
gonna just pull that up because why not
to do so yeah so that's what I'm talking
about it's just a property data type
yes mr. Larry so in that example is sort
of what the no theater would be
accustomed another customer quality oh
yeah what the what the different
property of a different gate that's
exactly right yeah it would be a
different property of a different date
but otherwise the same data and in this
way we would basically be keeping every
revision of the node that we had
enabling the time-machine aspect um um
call that get four graphs you know cuz
you can even branch with it you really
can I've seen people do that um any
other questions any online all right
thanks a lot guys we hit our time while
we're over by two minutes
[Applause]